eine mysteriöse insel heimgesucht vom
krankheit
ihre todesumstände verfolgen die
inselbewohner bis heute eine geweigert
sich hierher zu kommen
ein fortschrittlicher bau der nicht nur
glanz sondern auch tragik verkörpert
[Musik]
es ist ein merkwürdiger ort die
tragödien die sich hier abgespielt haben
im letzten jahrhundert spiegeln unsere
vergangenheit wieder
ein riesiger schwimmkran den ein
trauriges ende ereilt hat
dieses schiff kann viel es sollte nicht
auf diesen felsen festsitzen
und das stillgelegte meisterwerk eines
weltbekannten ingenieurs er hatte einen
plan aber den fanden einige extrem und
gefährlich
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden diese anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
aber wer hat sie erschaffen und wie und
weshalb sind sie verlassen
[Musik]
vor den toren berlins im
brandenburgischen elstal steht eine
ansammlung von gebäuden
einst schaute die welt hierher
heute sieht man fast nur noch ruinen
wenige deutsche kennen diesen ort er ist
in vergessenheit geraten möglicherweise
absichtlich
es gibt sogar ein schwimmbad das ohne
wasser vor sich hin rottet
es wird einem richtig mulmig wenn man
vor dem gut drei meter tiefen leeren
becken steht
und einen nur ein stiller kalter luftzug
an haut
ein abgenutztes sportpferd allein in
einer turnhalle drumherum stehen häuser
manche sogar mit veranda inmitten
saftiger grasflächen
wenn man sich die bungalow artigen
zweckbauten so ansieht
könnte man meinen dass sie zu einem
firmengelände gehören
allerdings stören baracken artige
wohnblöcke und militärisch anmutende
wandbilder den eindruck
sie sind hässlich und scheinen nicht
wirklich erhaltenswert
an den wänden kleben alte zeitungen und
wenn man näher hinschaut sieht man dass
die artikel gar nicht auf deutsch sind
die architektur ist von zwei bestimmten
spielen geprägt wobei alle gebäude
zusammen ein größeres ganzes ergeben
anlage vermittelt dass hier menschen
geformt
und zwar sehr viele
welchen zweck
das erschließt sich nicht sofort
auf dem 15 hektar großen gelände beginnt
1934 unter der regie der wehrmacht der
bau des olympischen dorfes für die
spiele der elften olympiade
wolfgang fürstner ist kommandant des
hochmodernen sportler quartiers die
olympischen sommerspiele die 1936 in
berlin beginnen bringen den nazis
international einen enormen
prestigegewinn
doch trotz des erfolgs der olympischen
spiele begibt sich wolfgang förstner
kurz nach deren ende ans ufer eines sees
und erschießt sich
fürstner war für den bau des olympischen
dorfes zuständig er wurde aber gemobbt
und an den rand gedrängt so dass er sich
entschloss seinem leben ein ende zu
setzen
kein schritt den man von einem
erfolgreichen offizier und
sportfunktionär erwartet
janukowitsch ist ein künstler der sich
ausführlich mit der geschichte des
olympischen dorfs beschäftigt hat
[Musik]
diese anlage spiegelt viel von der
vergangenheit wieder von den kriegen und
tragödien des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
manch einer kam hier zu tode einerseits
war hier platz für die schönheit der
jugend aber auch für tragik und tod
von seiten der ns-führung wurde das
olympische dorf offiziell alsdorf des
friedens bezeichnet obwohl von anfang an
eine spätere militärische nutzung
geplant war mit der machtergreifung im
jahr 1933 hatte hitler die ehrenvolle
aufgabe geerbt 1936 die spiele der elfte
olympiade in berlin auszurichten
dafür hatte die demokratische regierung
der weimarer republik
1931 den zuschlag bekommen
jetzt im jahre 1936 bekommt hitler die
gelegenheit der welt ein neu
aufgestelltes modernes deutschland zu
präsentieren
hitler der drei jahre zuvor die macht an
sich gerissen hatte will die olympiade
nutzen um der ganzen welt zu zeigen dass
die weimarer republik passé ist und dass
deutschland die wirtschaftskrise
überwunden hat
hitler wollte die vorlage der amerikaner
noch übertreffen dieser hatte 1932 die
olympischen spiele in los angeles
ausgerichtet und holzbaracken als
unterkünfte für die angereisten sportler
gebaut
die olympischen spiele in los angeles
waren für die deutschen ein wichtiges
vorbild denn hier wurde zum ersten mal
ein richtiges olympisches dorf gebaut
dass alle beeindruckt hat auch die
deutschen
sie haben sich von den amerikanern viel
abgeschaut und versucht das was sie
gesehen haben noch zu übertreffen
unter der regie von hauptmann wolfgang
fürstner entsteht ein hochmodernes
olympisches dorf 18 kilometer vom
olympiastadion in berlin entfernt rund
3600 männliche sportler aus fast 50
nationen leben hier zusammen so zum
beispiel berühmtheiten wie der deutsche
boxer max schmeling und der
amerikanische leichtathlet jesse owens
hier an den häusern sieht man die
neuerungen die die deutschen bei diesem
olympischen dorf eingeführt haben
es bestand nicht mehr nur aus temporären
holzbaracken sondern aus steinhäusern
mit terrassen zum sonnenbaden
dazu gab es in zentralheizung und
anderen luxus der viele sportler die
1936 angereist waren wirklich
beeindruckt hat
was die athleten neben telefon und
fließend warmem wasser noch mehr
beeindruckt ist der fernseh saal in dem
sie die wettkämpfe live verfolgen können
die medien spielten bei der inszenierung
der olympiade eine riesige rolle und
dienten propagandazwecken
so zb auch die zwei olympia filme von
leni riefenstahl
dazu übertrug das radio die olympischen
spiele zum ersten mal live sowie auch
das fernsehen das hier seine premiere
gefeiert hat
im sogenannten hindenburg haus wo viele
kulturveranstaltungen stattfinden
präsentiert ein wandbild den
militärischen geist der nazis
jedem der das bild sah musste klar sein
dass es bei dieser art der propaganda
darum ging die neue militärische stärke
deutschlands zu feiern
und nur ein paar jahre nach dem ende der
olympischen spiele sahen viele europäer
das gleiche bild wieder
als die deutschen tatsächlich
einmarschierten und ihre länder
besetzten
doch die gäste im dorf des friedens
interessieren sich mehr für die
hervorragenden sportanlagen
überhaupt schafft es hitler mit den
olympischen sommerspielen
1936 der welt das bild eines
friedliebenden weltoffenen deutschlands
vorzugaukeln trotz der rassistischen
politik seit seiner machtergreifung
selbst großbritannien und die usa
die deshalb die spiele boykottieren
sollten lassen sich ein neuen
nur die sowjetunion und ihre verbündeten
halten sich an den angekündigten boykott
in der internationalen wahrnehmung
bleiben moderne sportstätten und
technische errungenschaften im
gedächtnis hängen wie zum beispiel das
fernsehen mit erster live übertragungen
außerdem gibt es bei den olympischen
spielen in berlin noch andere neuerungen
die nazis hatten es echt raus auf
paraden mit licht und feuer zu spielen
es war ihre idee den olympischen
fackellauf wieder aufleben zu lassen den
ganzen weg von griechenland nach berlin
aber abseits des scheinwerferlichts
allen lippenbekenntnissen zum trotz
machen sie mit ihrer rassistischen
politik weiter
die deutschen erlaubten zwar juden an
den spielen teilzunehmen aber hinter den
kulissen trieben sie sinti und roma
zusammen und setzten gnadenlos ihre
antisemitischen gesetze um kurz vor
beginn der olympischen spiele war
wolfgang fürstner zum vize kommandanten
des olympischen dorfs heruntergestuft
worden
seine abberufung hatte anscheinend damit
zu tun dass einer seiner großväter jude
war
hier unten am see hat sich dann drei
tage nach der schlussfeier der
sommerspiele eine tragödie abgespielt
wolfgang fürstner kam von seinem haus
durch den wald hierher und er schoss
sich mit seiner dienstpistole
die nazis versuchten den selbstmord als
autounfall zu kaschieren
journalisten bringen später die wahrheit
ans licht
fürstner war nicht nur von seinem
führungsposten abgelöst worden der
berufsoffizier musste sogar mit seiner
entlassung aus der wehrmacht rechnen
weil er keinen ariernachweis beibringen
konnte
entschied er sich deshalb für den
freitod
nach den sechswöchigen sommerspielen
zieht die wehrmacht ins olympische dorf
ein sowie von anfang an geplant
allerdings nicht für lange denn die
kriegerischen jahre die bald folgen
bringen wieder neue bewohner mit sich
hier sieht man noch die spuren der roten
armee die 1945 hier eingezogen ist
jetzt haben nicht nur sachen wie diese
hier zurückgelassen auch ihre zeitungen
kleben noch an den wänden die pravda
kann man hier immer noch finden die rote
armee erweitert den militärstützpunkt um
mehrere fünf stücke gebauten
nach dem krieg war aufs meer stationiert
der militärische nachrichtendienst der
sowjetunion der auch ex nazis aufspüren
sollte
man munkelt dass die keller und das
schwimmbad als orte für verhöre und zur
folter genutzt wurden
mit dem ende der sowjetunion kommt 1991
auch das aus für den militärstützpunkt
im elztal
als sich die rote armee 1994 ganz aus
deutschland verabschiedet fällt das
gelände für rund 25 jahre in einen
dornröschenschlaf
erst vor kurzem kam die idee auf vier
modernen wohnraum zu schaffen
man kann noch die sprunganlage sehen wo
jesse owens einer der großartigsten us
sportler aller zeiten trainiert hat und
den parcours wo der boxer max schmeling
sich fit gemacht hat für seinen großen
tag jetzt soll einiges abgerissen und
einiges saniert werden den anfang macht
das denkmalgeschützte speisehaus der
nationen in dem rund 100
eigentumswohnungen entstehen sollen auch
für familien
elf kilometer vom venezolanischen
festland entfernt liegt die insel
tschaka tschaka die zum karibischen
inselstaat trinidad und tobago gehört
aber sie ist nicht bekannt für ihre
schönheit sondern für krankheit
wenn man diese insel vom wasser aus
betrachtet dann sieht sie aus wie
gemacht für ein typisches ferien resort
aber wenn man sich nähert sieht man alte
gebäude im kolonialstil die aussehen als
ob sie demnächst zusammenfallen
direkt am wasser steht etwas verloren
und vernachlässigt eine alte villa davor
ragt eine kaputte bier ins meer im
dschungel dahinter gibt es noch mehr
komische ruinen
einige gebäude sehen aus als ob sie zu
einem alten krankenhaus gehören oder zu
einem kirchengelände klar ist dass hier
eine größere anlage in betrieb war man
bekommt den eindruck dass die leute die
hierher kamen die insel nie mehr
verlassen haben
es gibt gräber nicht ein paar sondern
einen ganzen friedhof all das legt nahe
dass auf dieser einsamen insel einst
eine ganze gemeinde gelebt hat
was auch immer hier passiert ist es hat
den bewohnern offensichtlich angst und
schrecken eingeflößt
einige fischer aus der gegend fürchten
sich bis heute einen fuß auf die insel
zu setzen
das war nicht immer so noch
vor hundert jahren lebten viele
inselbewohner vom kommerziellen walfang
es war ein fischerdorf und dann auch ein
ferienparadies es ist ziemlich
ungemütlich wurde
[Musik]
1924 verändern sich die
lebensbedingungen auf der insel
dramatisch als die britischen
kolonialherren versuchen eine schwere
infektionskrankheit unter kontrolle zu
bekommen
lepra
dafür eröffnen sie hier in sciacca ca
eine kolonie für erkrankte aus der
hauptstadt port of spain
michael ford hat sich lange mit dem
thema beschäftigt
sie heißt sonders bay war nur für frauen
bestimmt nach kokos bate die bucht
daneben durften nur männer die leute
kamen bei kassen an und mussten sich in
diesem gebäude dort melden hier wurden
sie registriert und den entsprechenden
häusern zugeteilt wenn jemand zu krank
war um sich dort selbst zu versorgen kam
er oder sie ins krankenhaus
die neuankömmlinge waren unfreiwillig
opfer des sozialen wandels geworden
trinidad ist ab 1814 eine britische
kolonie als die briten 1833 die
sklaverei ab schaffen haben die besitzer
von zucker kokosnuss und
baumwollplantagen auf einmal zu wenig
arbeiter
eine welle neuer einwanderer erreichte
trinidad und tobago unter ihnen auch
leprakranke die neuankömmlinge
schleppten eine der weltweit
gefürchteten infektionskrankheiten ein
lepra ist eine vernichtende und wirklich
tragische krankheit ausgelöst wird sie
durch ein bakterium das unter der haut
lebt und sich langsam über die jahre
ausbreitet dabei verursachten
nervenschäden und kann im gesicht und an
körperteilen zur schrecklichen
einstellungen führen
über die jahrhunderte hatte es in der
karibik hin und wieder lepra fälle
gegeben aber durch die migranten wie bis
ende des 19 jahrhunderts in trinidad
ankommen entwickelt sich die krankheit
zu einer epidemie
die furcht die kontrolle über die
hochansteckende unheilbare und
schreckliche krankheit zu verlieren war
groß
um die epidemie in den griff zu bekommen
beschlossen die behörden die
leprakranken zu erfassen und zu
isolieren
[Musik]
erkrankten wurden aus ihren familien
gerissen auf boote gebracht und
verschifft ein leben in völliger
isolation
und hierher wurden sie gebracht in die
lepra kolonie auf sprecher kari
als diese 1924 in betrieb geht ist platz
für rund 300 patienten die auf zwei
booten verteilt werden sollen versorgt
mit dem nötigsten wohnen sie hier
abgeschnitten von der außenwelt ist die
medizinische anlage versorgte sich
selbst es gab wohnräume ein krankenhaus
und eine wäscherei
das hinter mir ist so eine typische
behausungen der die patienten
untergebracht waren von denen gab es
hier ungefähr 50 üblicherweise wohnten
darin zwei patienten mit etwas hausrat
kleinen küchen fließend wasser und einer
kleinen veranda
obwohl die leprakranken ein dach über
dem kopf haben führen sie eine traurige
existenz
das leben für die patienten war nicht
leicht männer und frauen liebten völlig
getrennt
romanzen oder so eine art familienleben
dass man ja hinlänglich mit dem
menschsein verbindet da nicht möglich
außerdem mussten sie arbeiten bekamen
aber nur 25 cent für einen tag das
wasser war knapp darum sammelten sie
regenwasser sie durften noch nicht
einmal schwimmen gehen nur brust tief
ins wasser tauchen wer sich nicht an die
regeln hielt riskierte eine strafe das
schlimmste wer einmal hierher geschickt
wurde
kam nicht mehr weg
die leprakranken durften keine gäste
empfangen und auch nicht ihre familien
zu hause besuchen
und obwohl es so aussah als ob sie hier
in einem tropischen paradies lebten war
es für sie eher eine art vorhölle aus
der sie nicht mehr raus kamen sie
konnten wieder zurück zu ihrer familie
noch ein neues leben starten
vergleichbar mit dem früheren
bis heute vermeiden es die einheimischen
die insel zu betreten
diese gräber vermitteln einen teil des
leids von dem es hier viel gab
eine gruppe von dominikanerinnen
kümmerte sich um die aussätzigen die
nonnen kamen aus frankreich und lebten
unter den gleichen bedingungen wie die
leprakranken das war gefährlich und sie
litten an der seite ihrer patienten
29 steckten sich an und starben an lepra
eine von ihnen tötete sich selbst was
gerade nicht tun sollten es gibt die
legende dass sie immer noch hier herum
spukt die einige einheimische weigern
sich bis heute einen fuß auf diese insel
zu setzen sie fürchten sich vielmehr vor
dem geist der nonne als vor dem erbe der
lepra kolonie
die aussätzigen von chaka chaka scheinen
verdammt ihr leben ist geprägt von der
aussicht auf einstellung und einen
frühen tod dies ändert sich im jahr 1942
als neuankömmlinge frischen wind mit
sich bringen es handelt sich um 1.000
die us marines
die amerikaner bauten auf der ganzen
insel beraten und sie installierten
dieselgeneratoren das verbesserte die
lebensqualität auf der insel entscheiden
zum ersten mal gibt es nun elektrischen
strom inter lepra kolonie
hinzu kommt dass die regeln gelockert
werden und männer und frauen nicht mehr
getrennt voneinander leben müssen und
dass es in der medizin neue erkenntnisse
gibt bei dem mit mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts verbesserten sich die
behandlungsmöglichkeiten für lepra die
symptome ließen sich durch eine
kombination von antibiotika linda mit
den zunehmenden möglichkeiten die
chronische infektionskrankheit zu
behandeln wächst auch die bereitschaft
die erkrankten nicht mehr weg zu sperren
dazu hatten die dominikanerinnen
nachwuchsprobleme es kamen immer weniger
nonnen um die älteren zu ersetzen die
entweder sterben oder selbst zu
pflegefällen wurden was letztendlich zur
schließung der lepra kolonie geführt hat
auf schakale leben immer weniger
menschen am 23 juli 1984 verließ der
letzte patient die insel
danach wurde die anlage sich selbst
überlassen
seither gab es immer wieder pläne die
insel für den tourismus zu erschließen
1999 überlegte sogar donald trump ihr
ein casino mit hotel zu bauen ließ dann
aber doch die finger davon
bietet das frühere leiter der kranken
heute schutz für flora und fauna
vor der südafrikanischen küste nahe der
hafenstadt kapstadt steht eine etwas
ungewöhnliche sehenswürdigkeit im meer
die natur in dieser gegend ist von
faszinierender schönheit
da ist der atlantische ozean mit seiner
bergkulisse und dann steht da plötzlich
etwas das absolut nicht hierher gehört
auf einmal sticht einem dieses
riesenwerk ins auge
ein schiff das vor der felsigen küste
auf grund gelaufen ist mit einem kran
drauf der sich richtung himmel reckt ein
teil der konstruktion liegt unter wasser
der rostige drehte mit kran darüber
lässt ahnen wie groß das ganze gebilde
sein muss
[Musik]
das che das schiff und sein kran hatten
offensichtlich einst eine besondere
aufgabe diese sehr spezielle schiffs
konstruktion sollte nicht auf diesen
felsen festsitzen
auf dem meer kann so einiges schief
gehen darum gibt es ja auch seit
jahrhunderten eine bergungs industrie
die sich um schiffe kümmert die
repariert oder recycelt werden sollen
aber hier ist offensichtlich etwas
schiefgegangen denn dieser schwimmende
kran wurde nicht geborgen warum hat sich
niemand um ihn gekümmert
es ist doch klar dass ihr irgend ein
unglück passiert sein muss und man fragt
sich wie es kommen konnte dass dieses
wasser gefährt auf diesen felsen
gelandet ist
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt 1994 damals
bekommt der südafrikanische
bergungsexperten captain slow meinen
anruf
die bucht bietet großen schiffen bei
unwetter perfekten schutz wir wussten
dass ein sturm im anzug war und
unterbrachen unsere aktivitäten in einem
supertanker
und dann rief die hafenbehörde cup
starts an und sagte uns dass die boss
400 auf die küste zu triebe
und das ist die boss 400
das schiff wurde in einer französischen
werft für besondere aufgaben gebaut
[Musik]
basically ab sie ist ein rohr
verlegeschiff einzig und allein dafür
entworfen rohre für riesige öl pipelines
zu heben von a nach b zu bewegen und zu
verlegen
sie wurde beim bau von bohrinseln
angefordert und ist um die ganze welt
geschippert um diese risiken bauten
unter oft schwierigen bedingungen
möglich zu machen
jahrhundert war eines der
leistungsfähigsten offshore construction
boote das je gebaut wurde
sie war am bau von einigen der größten
bohrinseln der welt beteiligt
der kran konnte lasten bis zu 1200
tonnen heben das ganze schwimmende
konstrukt hatte einen wert von über 70
millionen dollar
aber die küste vor kapstadt ist
gefährlich und captains lohn ist klar
dass dies die letzte reise der boss 400
sein könnte
es gibt hier stürme die ihren ursprung
in brasilien haben sich dann über dem
atlantischen ozean weiter aufbauen und
dann mit voller wucht auf die küste
treffen wenn sie sich dann noch mit der
warmen luft vom land herr mission nehmen
sie noch mehr fahrt auf es ist also
keine gute idee vor südafrika in einen
sturm zu geraten
dieser küstenabschnitt ist besonders
tückisch und bekannt für wechselhaftes
wetter und stürmer die cup spitze wird
darum auch kap der stürme genannt
diese rohr verlegeschiffe haben keinen
motor sie werden von schleppern bewegt
am tag des unglücks wird die boss 400
die zuletzt im kongo im einsatz war von
einem russischen schiff namens tigre
gezogen da sich so ein rohr
verlegeschiff nicht aus eigener kraft
fortbewegen kann braucht es einen
kräftigen und wendigen schlepper um von
a nach b zu kommen
aber es gibt probleme mit dem schlepper
der die boss 400 mit einer über 1200
meter langen verbindungs leine zieht
sein hauptmotor ist ausgefallen
wenn nur noch der reserve motor
funktioniert dann ist so ein boot
natürlich nicht mehr ausreichend
manövrierfähig dazu bestand die gefahr
dass dieser mutter auch noch ausfällt
denn dies war ein ungewöhnlich starker
sturm
die schiffsbesatzung ahnt noch nicht
dass sie in großer gefahr schwebt
der hafen von kapstadt hatte schon dicht
gemacht aber der schlepper hielt immer
noch darauf zu
irgendwann haben sie dann versucht zu
drehen womit die schwierigkeiten so
richtig anfangen die schlepper crew
hatte über funk schon mehrere warnungen
bekommen aber weil ihr englisch so
schlecht war haben die seeleute sie
nicht verstanden und weitergemacht und
bei dem versuch zu drehen und weit
heraus auf see zu fahren ist das
schleppseil aus stahl auf den
meeresboden gesunken und an einem riff
gerissen
jetzt sind die crews auf beiden schiffen
in gefahr nix bergungsteam nähert sich
so schnell es geht während das
schwerfällige rohr verlegeschiff auf die
fans küste zutreibt
wir kamen von vsp um zu sehen ob wir
noch ein abschleppseil um das wir
pflegen könnten aber die
wetterbedingungen waren so schlimm dass
uns dabei auch ein helikopter nichts
genützt hätte geht in der sommersaison
sind die wellen so ein bis eineinhalb
meter hoch
aber damals waren sie ungefähr so hoch
wie das kranführer häuschen
um das mal zu verdeutlichen
die wellen waren so hoch dass die boss
400 trotz ihrer größe zeitweise unter
den bogen verschwand
unter diesen umständen ist es für das
bergungsteam einfach zu gefährlich eine
neue verbindung kleine an dem boot zu
befestigen
wir mussten tatenlos zuschauen wie die
boss 400 langsam zerbrach ein helikopter
rettete die crew während sich mutter
natur an dem schiff austobte und es auf
die felsen schleuderte die sich in den
rumpf worten
[Musik]
aber für die crew war der horror trip
trotz der luftrettung noch nicht vorbei
im hafen von kapstadt angekommen werden
die seeleute verhaftet und verhört um
herauszufinden wie es zu dem desaster
kommen konnte
außerdem wollen die behörden alles
versuchen um ein schiff dieser
größenordnung doch noch zu bergen
[Musik]
wir warten auf besseres wetter und
schickten beim zweiten rettungsversuch
mehrere kleine boote zum wrack dazu
setzen wir mit dem helikopter leute an
bord ab die den schaden einschätzen
sollten die schiffs tanks rechts unten
saßen auf dem riff fest wenn man hier
ein schiff nicht innerhalb von 24
stunden frei bekommt schwinden die
chancen auf erfolg
diese lektion lernt auch eine
amerikanische firma die später noch
einen weiteren erfolglosen
rettungsversuch startet parallel dazu
beginnt ein gerichtsverfahren in dessen
zuge einige crew-mitglieder des
russischen schleppers über sechs jahre
festgehalten werden bevor sie endgültig
nach hause dürfen
der hai den untersuchungen kam heraus
dass der antrieb des schleppers viel zu
schwach war und dass das boot der
aufgabe nicht gewachsen war
die versicherungssumme belief sich auf
80 millionen dollar das war auch der
grund warum die crew der tiger in haft
blieb und die eigner des boots zur
verantwortung gezogen werden sollten
aber die hatten natürlich auch nicht so
viel geld oder eine entsprechende
versicherung
es war ein totalverlust für die
französischen besitzer des schiffs und
für die versicherer
irgendwann wird auch der schlepper
versteigert
aber der erlös ist nur ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein die boss 400 zu bergen
bleibt einfach zu gefährlich
aber wenigstens ist sie heute eine
sehenswürdigkeit für touristen haika und
taucher
und wer weiß wofür sie sonst noch gut
ist
[Musik]
von der unterkonstruktion des schiffs
hatten nicht viele überlebt was den kran
angeht da würde es mich nicht wundern
wenn er in den nächsten vier fünf jahren
ins wasser kippt aber selbst das erhöht
wahrscheinlich den freizeitwert für
taucher und wer weiß vielleicht entsteht
ja so ein künstliches riff oder ein ganz
neues ökosystem
[Musik]
in der üppigen landschaft im südwesten
von england gibt es ein tal mit
ungewöhnlichen ruinen
sweep mitten in der hinreißend schönen
landschaft von cornwall steht ein
großartiges viadukt aus stein dass ein
flusstal überspannt aber wenn man sich
dem bauwerk nähert sieht man dass da
noch etwas anderes steht
direkt daneben sind ein paar andere
säulen die offensichtlich noch viel
älter sind und eine eigene geschichte
erzählen
für welchen zweck wurden diese säulen
gebaut warum stehen sie so verlassen da
was wurde aus dem bauprojekt ist es
zusammengekracht oder wurde es
absichtlich zerstört
mystery die die sache wird immer
mysteriöser
wenn man entlang der säulen nach oben
schaut sie enden ohne dass eine brücke
darüber führt
der erste eindruck legt nahe dass hier
ein recht gewöhnliches bauwerk stand
aber das ist nicht der fall
im schlussteil selbst kann man sehen
dass der boden schlammig und was sumpfig
ist er sieht jedenfalls nicht sehr
tragfähig aus es ist eine art marschland
die erde ist nicht sehr tief das ist
kein bauland für eine komplexe
technische konstruktion
das bauwerk dass hier einst stand hatte
nicht nur pioniercharakter es war auch
kontrovers und wurde verhöhnt
seine geschichte ist verbunden mit der
eines weltberühmten ingenieurs
[Musik]
heutzutage fahren hier schnellzüge und
überqueren das tal über ein viadukt aus
stein damals im neunzehnten jahrhundert
waren es dampflokomotiven die die
wirtschaft des vereinigten königreichs
auf touren brachten in cornwall spielte
der bergbau eine große rolle ohne
eisenbahn wäre die region abgehängt
worden
es war wichtig für die leute das
geschäft und den handel dass es eine
eisenbahnverbindung zu den
hauptverkehrszeiten gab die nach london
führten
der bahnlinie auf flachen land zu bauen
ist relativ simpel in cornwall dagegen
ist das nicht so einfach da hat man
flusstäler und steilen hügel und da wird
die sache gleich etwas komplizierter und
dieses tal war eine besondere
herausforderung
sie bauten dutzende brücken und
kilometer lange bahnstrecke aber wenn
sie dieses tal nicht überquert hätten
wäre alles umsonst gewesen
um das tal zu überqueren braucht man das
viadukt
dies sind die überreste des ersten
kernen viadukts
ursprünglich bestand der plan eine rund
230 meter lange brücke auf 11 pfeilern
zu bauen ein ehrgeiziges projekt für den
damaligen brückenbauer
der ortsansässige historiker bob
richards erklärt warum
dies war eines der tiefsten täler auf
der route die sie überwinden mussten das
gleisbett lag ungefähr 30 meter über dem
talboden
[Musik]
um ein viadukt zu bauen das eine weile
hält braucht man einen stabilen und
flachen untergrund und das an diesem ort
zu erreichen ist nicht ganz einfach denn
der talboden ist mit schlamm bedeckt der
an einigen stellen bis zu sechs meter
tief ist
damals lag der wasserspiegel noch höher
außerdem ist er von den gezeiten
abhängig das erschwerte die bauarbeiten
und die konstruktions bedingungen es
schien als hätte sich alles gegen die
planer verschworen
das viadukt zu bauen ist eine
strukturelle und technologische
herausforderung der man an denen die
aufgabe heran getragen wird ist schon
damals ein berühmter ingenieur
zu der zeit gab es eigentlich nur eine
person die diese spezielle problem lösen
konnte ist in barking im rennen
real macht sich in der zeit der
industriellen revolution einen namen und
gilt bis heute als einer der
herausragendsten britischen ingenieure
1806 wird er in portsmouth geboren
sein vater ist ein französischer
ingenieur die mutter engländerin bringen
gilt als frühreif sein vater lehrt in
geometrie und französisch nach einer
lehre in paris als uhrmacher holt in
sein vater 1822 als assistent nach
london zurück hier soll er an einem
tunnel projekt mitarbeiten dass unter
der themse durchführt von rover hat nach
mobbing
wenige denken damals dass er schon bald
innovative eisenbahn wege dampfschiffe
tunnel und brücken bauen würde die das
bild derzeit prägen
[Musik]
am bekanntesten ist wahrscheinlich die
clifton hängebrücke in brüssel die
damals die brücke mit der größten
spannweite der welt war
auch die eisenbahn und schiffsindustrie
haben so unglaublich von green l 's
vision profitiert dass er in der skala
der beliebtesten briten auf platz zwei
rangiert direkt hinter churchill
[Musik]
aber selbst für einen brillanten
ingenieure wie brunel ist das kann ein
viadukt eine herausforderung
[Musik]
er hatte eine lösung für das problem
aber was er vorschlug galt bei einigen
als extrem und als gefährlich
er schlug vor den oberen teil des
viadukts nicht aus stein sondern aus
holz zu bauen das wäre billiger
schneller und einfacher für die arbeiter
die leute zweifelten aber daran ob eine
holzstruktur stabil genug für
eisenbahnzüge war
real entwarf gerüstteile aus holz die
sich von den steinen sollen her nach
oben auffächerte um dann die
eisenbahntrasse aus holz zu tragen es
war ein sehr innovativer entwurf und die
verwendung von holz anstatt von stein
sollte viel geld sparen
rinners ansatz war sehr ungewöhnlich für
die zeit und wurde anfangs von der
presse ins lächerliche gezogen
in der zeit um 1860 herum war dieser
ansatz den leuten zu modern sie hatten
angst und zweifelten an der
tragfähigkeit
heutzutage können wir darin eine stabile
und zukunftsweisende struktur erkennen
das war damals anders
als einfallsreiche entwurf aus holz ist
umstritten heute steht hier ein neues
viadukt
ist heute noch sehen wir diese säulen
aus stein diese stunden mit nichts
darauf hat das holz überlebt ist es
zusammengekracht was ist passiert
man darf holz nicht unterschätzen es
sieht vielleicht nicht so stabil aus wie
stein hält aber viel aus wenn es richtig
verbaut wird kann man über
holzkonstruktionen unglaubliche mengen
an gewicht transportieren schnell und
sicher
britz entwurf funktionierte auch
tatsächlich unter anderem weil er den
boden des flussbettes so gut vorbereitet
hatte
der großteil des gewichts wurde über die
steine sollen abgeleitet die hier im
boden verankert sind
die aufgefächerte holzkonstruktion
darüber verteilte das gewicht
gleichmäßig über die 230 meter
gesamtlänge der brücke
die stützpfeiler aus hartem stein wurden
tief in den boden hinein gebaut was der
konstruktion ihre stabilität und
tragfähigkeit verliebt bringen nutzte
bei dem bau all seine erfahrung und all
seinen talenten
konstruktionen aus stahl tief hinein ins
flussbett getrieben und dann den ganzen
schlamm und schlick raus gepumpt dadurch
konnten die arbeiter so tief unten diese
stabilen fundament aus stein bauen
durch die tief gesetzten stahl ringe
bleiben die fundamente trocken und
erlangen trotz des instabilen bodens
besondere standfestigkeit der weiche
boden hat brunel sicher kopfzerbrechen
bereitet aber er hat die daraus
resultierenden probleme mit seinem
entwurf gelöst die säulen stehen da bis
heute felsenfest
über 70 jahre ratterten züge über dieses
viktorianische meisterwerk
leider konnte sein schöpfer es nie in
betrieb sehen denn brunner starb noch
vor der fertigstellung
aber warum gibt es die brücke heute
nicht mehr
sie war zwar lange im einsatz aber am
ende wurden die wartungs und
instandsetzungskosten zu hoch besonders
was den oberen bereich aus holz anging
in den 1930 er jahren beschließt die
bahnbehörde green als wär doch durch
einen neubau zu ersetzen der
ausschließlich aus stein besteht
aber sein bemerkenswertes werk war eine
der letzten originalen
holzkonstruktionen die in cornwall
ersetzt worden
heute fahren hauptsächlich touristen auf
der neuen strecke die parallel zu den
noch erhaltenen säulen von green l
verläuft
[Musik]
alles was im boot kingdom brunel gebaut
hat sollte lange halten diese säulen
sind ein gutes beispiel für sein genie
als ingenieur und für die unglaubliche
handwerkskunst der arbeiter immerhin
stehen sie nun schon rund 150 160 jahre
zeit sie gebaut wurden
[Musik]
heute sind sie verfassen aber sie
zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt
diese verfallenden konstruktionen sind
ein echo der vergangenheit sie erzählen
von krieg und schrecken aber auch von
entdeckergeist und
fortschritt
[Musik]